salut connard bas bon je tire les
questions qu on al harbi sont là dis moi
tu préférais de bloquée dans un
ascenseur avec drucker savatier fabrique
ce boîtier jean pierre roche m'en fous
je m'en fous sont aussi gentils les uns
que les autres
j'adore drucker j'adore sabatier j'adore
hypocrite et qu'on dit moi est-ce que tu
préférerais nique et enfin faire l'amour
puisqu'on est sur service public est-ce
que tu préférais te faire une femme
vieille très très laide ou un mec super
beau genre stallone jouer sur scène et
guérir je préfère une vitre latérale est
calme à l'incarnation je sais qu'ils
croient pas beaucoup mais tu préfères
être réincarné en berger allemand
on n'est pas mieux le breton ou ans et
erland et aux non je préférerais être
incarné tu sais en quoi bouffer baiser
bouffer baiser bouffer baiser être lapin
dans le gers
ça ne m'étonne pas tu pense qu'à ça
qu'est-ce qu'ils se feraient plus peur
en rentrant chez toi le soir dans le
noir dit pas le nom du noir mais enfin
dans le noir qu'est ce qu'ils feraient
plus peur stone ou charden ni l'un ni
l'autre
j'aime bien me font pas peur ni l'un ni
l'autre n'y a pas de question de chanter
de 69 ans il chante pas qu'on n'a pas
dit que il chante et donc j'ai pas peur
si tu passais trois ans dans un vaisseau
spatial avec trois nanas qui tu
préférais alors dorothée anne sinclair
ou claire chazal l'e3
mais vraiment les trois avaient dorothée
anne sinclair est claire chazal et s'il
faut vraiment faire un choix entre eux
et moi je vais t'étonner dorothée
helsinn a pété les plombs
la bombe atomique va nous tomber sur la
gueule d'ici cinq minutes qu'est ce que
tu fais rien je profite des derniers
instants
dans cette émission finalement en me
disant que j'aurais pu mourir dans une
émission beaucoup plus con que ça bien
ce que je peux en fait un thème tout le
monde c'est pas une légende flatteur les
corrections de ne rien rater de l'ina
l'habitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux